[Musique]
ça fait longtemps que j'existe mon nom
jack frost
[Musique]
j'aime être libre pas de règles pas de
responsabilité puis le bonheur
salut lieu ça fait un bail depuis la
grande tempête de neige de 68 en plein
dimanche de pâques me dis pas que tu
m'en veux encore si si mais c'est pas
pour ça que je suis là grave
le voilà jack france père noël ça alors
j'espère que les y est tu tombe bien
traités j'adore il faudrait dans un sac
et balancé par un portail magique au
mieux
c'était mon idée les quatre légendes
réunit le père noël la fée des dents le
marchand de sable et la cloche de pâques
la cua je suis dans le pain nous avons
pour mission de protéger tous les
enfants du monde
la menace que nous devons affronter n'a
jamais été si grande qu'elle adorable
que peut-il y avoir de plus fort la peur
on a besoin de tout net
pourquoi moi tu as quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
nous ne les rendent pas sans toi mais
bon ça ben oui toi
qui ne peut pas faire fondre la peur car
je n'ai pas peur de toi
tous ensemble
[Musique]
tu t'occupes ce gaucher mois de soldes
droite
allez pas de quartier
c'est parti
j'ai pas été sage
tu bats le record